karan hizo una tabla que muestra cuánto
tiempo pasó haciendo tarea la semana
pasada y aquí vemos los temas y cuánto
tiempo pasó en horas por cada tema en
mate paso tres cuartos de hora en
lectura paso siete octavos de hora en
escritura paso tres sextos de hora y en
ciencia paso cinco décimos de hora
después nos preguntan en cuáles
actividades karen paso más de dos
tercios de hora pausa en el vídeo y
traten de resolverlo por su cuenta
lo que tenemos que hacer básicamente es
calcular cuáles de estas fracciones son
mayores a dos tercios de ahora cuáles
son mayores a dos tercios ya que todo
está en términos de horas primero veamos
cómo representar dos tercios vamos a
hacerlo aquí voy a dibujar a mano por lo
que no será perfecto si esto es un
entero lo divido en tres partes iguales
voy a tratar de hacerlo más o menos así
son tres partes iguales esto es un
tercio esto es otro tercio y esto es
otro tercio dos tercios son dos de estas
partes elijo las dos primeras aunque no
tienen por qué ser las dos primeras
partes veamos si podemos dibujar algo
similar para cada una de estas
fracciones veamos tres cuartos de nuevo
vamos a dibujar un entero y como ahora
estamos pensando en términos de cuartos
vamos a dividir este entero en cuatro
partes iguales aquí tengo dos partes
iguales y ahora divido ambas partes en
dos secciones iguales más o menos así
está hecho a mano pero son cuatro partes
iguales así que este es un cuarto este
es otro cuarto este es otro cuarto y
este es otro cuarto cuatro cuartos hacen
un entero tres de esos cuartos son uno
dos y tres
aquí podemos ver que aunque no es un
dibujo perfecto está bien hecho podemos
ver que tres cuartos es más cercano a un
entero que dos tercios es más grande que
dos tercios por lo que karen pasó más de
dos tercios de horas haciendo tarea de
mate porque tres cuartos es mayor a dos
tercios
esta opción me gusta por lo que la
señaló con un recuadro esto haré con los
temas en los que caben pasó más de dos
tercios de hora haciendo tarea ahora
veamos la lectura pasó siete octavos de
hora y para comparar lo vamos a dibujar
nuevamente un entero y como son siete
octavos vamos a dividir este entero en
ocho partes iguales aquí tenemos dos
partes iguales aquí tenemos cuatro
partes iguales
si divido en dos cada una de ellas
tenemos ocho partes iguales que son más
o menos así no son perfectas pero creo
que nos sirven cada una de estas partes
es un octavo por lo que siete octavos
son uno dos tres cuatro cinco seis y
siete de nuevo esto es mayor a los dos
tercios que tenemos en morado por lo que
ella pasó más de dos tercios de hora
haciendo tarea de lectura y que hay con
la escritura tres sextos como luce esto
vamos a dibujar otro entero que vamos a
dividir en tercios primero aprovechando
que ya tenemos una referencia a que
estos son tercios y si dividimos a la
mitad cada tercio nos quedarán sextos
que se ven más o menos así marcamos tres
de esos sextos uno dos tres por lo que
vemos que tres sextos es menor a dos
tercios por lo que no voy a señalar este
tema ya que ella no pasó más de dos
tercios de horas haciendo tarea de
escritura y por último pero no menos
importante
5 decimos nuevamente dibujamos un entero
que vamos a dividir en 10 partes iguales
aquí hay dos partes iguales y cada una
la puedo dividir en cinco partes iguales
1 2 3 4 5 más o menos así y 1 2 3 4 y 5
creo que podría haber quedado mejor pero
esto nos ayuda con lo que necesitamos
cada una de estas partes es un décimo
undécimo un décimo y esto lo puedo
escribir en todas las partes pero sólo
nos interesan 5 de estas partes 1 2 3 4
y 5 noten que cinco décimos es igual a
tres sextos y como tres sextos es menor
a dos tercios así que en cuáles
actividades karen paso más de dos
tercios de ahora claramente en mate y en
lectura